as is custom the february education
youth culture and sports council will
focus on education issues and on how
these can contribute to economic growth
jobs and social cohesion
in support of the so-called european
semester which is the six-month cycle of
economic policy coordination in the eu
launched by the commission's annual
growth survey
ministers will focus on innovative
education and training systems across
the eu to improve skills performance and
ensure that young people and low skilled
adults acquire the kind of skills and
competencies relevant to today's labor
market
ministers will also hold a public debate
on skills and employability in the light
of the results of two recent surveys by
the oecd
one which measured the performance of 15
year olds in reading maths and science
and an international assessment on the
skills of the adult population
the results of their discussion will
feed into the wider debate that would
take place during the next spring
european council in march